my name is Danielle Judy and I'm gonna
talk to you a little bit today about
crushing your technical resume a little
bit about myself I work with Robert Half
Technology so I see a lot of resumes and
I talked to a lot of hiring managers in
the technical space and some of you
might have really great resumes and some
of you might not it might be time to
dust it off so those amazed how it's
supposed to be oh okay cool doesn't look
like that online but that's fine okay
so five rules of a strong resume one
it's customized looking at the job that
you're applying for and actually making
it relevant to proofreading carefully
and looking for typos and grammar
aspects focusing on your accomplishments
not your job duties that's a really big
area and we'll get into all of these
more briefing to the point and reflects
you at your personal bust so Robert Half
we do a lot of surveys when it comes to
hiring managers and this was a recent
survey that we did that had about 2,200
hiring managers and talked about common
mistakes that people make on their
applications and obviously you can see
the biggest one being not customizing
the not customizing the resume to the
actual position some other ones in there
which I obviously are just as important
and echo those five roles would be
grammar including your relevant
information and looking at your
accomplishments and not just your job
duties so first off getting in a format
pretty simple your name your phone your
email and a github if you have one if
you don't I highly recommend
a developer that you start to put all
your code out there in a repository make
sure that your emails neutral and
professional a simple name you know we
all have work emails most of us versus I
love baby back ribs email comm you'd be
surprised how many people don't have
professional emails it's really easy you
guys just go out go to Gmail something
like that the other thing obviously
that's missing up here address it's not
really relevant anymore it used to be
but nowadays I mean everybody's gonna
get a hold of yourself or your email
then you should get into your intro and
and summary aspects looking at your
skills and going into your job history
job history should be chronological you
want to start with your older or I'm
sorry your current role at the top and
then work your way backwards so the so
first we have the intro summary this is
basically your first impression I have a
couple of different examples here both
of them I think are you know relevant
and ok to do but you want it straight
into the point you don't want it too
long obviously these look a little
longer because they're condensed with
the margins but but hit those high
levels of the position that you're
looking for and why you feel like you'd
be a good fit for it and you can do a
simple paragraph for some build-up
points next getting into the skills I
think this part is really important when
you're working with somebody or when
you're a developer and you're looking
for a job you can do this in a couple of
different ways I like it when it breaks
on you know what you've worked on on the
front end and the back end the specific
languages and development tools if you
do it great you can do different
different ways to present all that info
but ultimately it's not high-level stuff
make sure you're putting things on there
that you've actually worked with in a
professional capacity or can actually
like represent and talk about you don't
want to put something on there just
because you you know you dabbled with it
a little bit
some some codecademy or whatnot you
should feel pretty proficient in it and
able to talk about it next getting into
job history and your content like I
mentioned before you want to tailor your
resume to the opportunity I know it
sounds like a pain in the butt but
honestly it's really gonna help
especially depending on the company and
if their specific experience that you
can apply to it make sure when you're
going through your job history a good
way to not do too much just did you you
know just a short overview a couple
sentences and then some bullet points
beneath it with your most important
achievements accomplishments things like
that that you've done within the job I
you want to focus on within those bullet
points focus on areas that included
problem solving and how you went about
it that's one thing that I'd say a lot
of managers will push back about is that
you just have a list of job duties as
opposed to things that you've actually
gone through you've done and I like to
tell people it's okay to brag about
yourself a little bit that's kind of you
know what these areas are for
demonstrating how and why that echoes
the accomplishments aspects especially
in technology you know there's not every
answer not every problem has the same
answer you can you can solve it in
multiple different ways so you know a
little bit on why you took that approach
and and being able to actually talk
about it in depth pick a few projects
out there those high-level ones again
that you want to brag about tools and
technologies this should go back to that
first part that talks about your skills
but putting in there the languages and
the tools and whatnot that you used and
that can even be like a third bullet
point or a fourth or just kind of that
again that high level of what's
applicable to this certain certain job
value added an ROI a lot of people in
business want to see what value vatted
what money you've saved what time you've
saved what even if it's headcount people
anything that you can material
into numbers and/or money will look good
to a lot of people that are in a hiring
position if you don't know exactly we
talked to some of your teammates or just
you know to take us sit back and think
well if I'm automating this process that
means that you know the person who is
doing it saves X amount of hours a day
or whatever a week and you know try to
total that up it'll-it'll help out a
bunch another thing would be your
keywords incorporating terms from the
job description especially nowadays when
unless you're working through a
recruiter we're able to kind of help out
and highlight those areas but if you're
applying to jobs online using the terms
within the job description are gonna
help with that automated process and
that application black hole that happens
a lot of time with with online
applications all right
link this is a question I get a lot I'd
say there's no hard and fast rule for it
it should reflect the depth of your
experience so if you've been in the
industry for years having a one-page
resume just isn't gonna be sufficient
it should also it shouldn't gloss over
the important parts of your experience
I'd say like two to three pages is
pretty good if you're moving into five
six seven pages maybe take a step back
see what's relevant as a hiring manager
in somebody an HR recruiter most people
aren't gonna go five six pages back into
your resume just make sure you're
staying relevant and if your experience
is no longer relevant
I'm sorry relevant it's probably best to
leave it off I see this as well with a
technology that might be a little a
little older a little more legacy I mean
unless unless it's something really
impressive it's probably not going to be
applicable to the job and if you don't
have a ton of experience you don't want
to appear more qualified than you
actually are
I know it's hard getting your first job
and trying to talk about what you've
done but you don't don't feel obligated
to fill the whole page and then the
other stuff
so your accomplishments your
certifications if you have any awards
things like that you don't list those
towards the bottom education whether
it's a degree if you did certain
trainings that you went to through your
through your job if you've completed
code camps or I know that they do a lot
of code camps here things like that you
can definitely list on their references
leave them off just put under there you
know references available upon request
make sure that you have some references
ready if they ask for that but you know
you don't necessarily need to be putting
putting names out there and that's a
perfectly acceptable way to do it the
other part clear the clutter clutter
excuse me you want to leave your
personal information off that has little
or no relevance hobbies children I mean
just if it's not in a professional
aspect if it's volunteering here doing
something in that kind of a regard yeah
put that kind of stuff on there but if
it's not geared towards technology in
your professional pursuits leave it off
and like I said before ask yourself does
this add value to your resume errors and
typos I thought this was interesting
another Robert Half survey over 300
senior managers at 63 63 percent of them
said one did she resume mistakes would
eliminate an application an applicant
from consideration so we all have
friends have your friend you know check
over your resume I know that it can be
kind of a lot of people might hesitate
you know putting their resume in front
of somebody else and want to hear the
feedback from it sometimes it's good
sometimes it's bad but take that and
actually know edit it and make sure that
what you're submitting doesn't have
typos and errors and then cover letter
this is another question that we get as
a recruiter I'll be honest I don't do
much with cover cover letters I'm
looking where your
you know your most recent experience and
what you've done about what you've done
in the job there and you know talking
you about specifics of the things that
you've worked on but when it comes to if
you find a layoff if you've had a gap in
your employment or a career change those
are good things that you can address in
a cover letter and make sure that you're
professional about it and that's it yeah
so as far as resumes one question I
always have is is paragraph format
better or like bullet points
so what personally I like to see and
everybody's a little bit different but I
like to see a couple of sentences about
you know the high level of what that job
is what you came in to do what your day
to day is and then doing a couple of
bullet points after that as far as like
I mentioned the the technology that you
actually worked with some of the high
level projects that you worked on and
accomplished and some of that value at
at our ally anything else all right well
if you have anything else that you think
of I am on the tech Lahoma slack it's
not the best way to get a hold of me but
I'll try my best to keep up with it you
can also find me on LinkedIn or if you
feel free to email me